[Music]
you recognize the song of course but
maybe not the place it's being played
the star-spangled banner being performed
outside buckingham palace under queen
elizabeth's direction after the 9 11
attacks a sign of the special
relationship between our two countries
the queen met with 13 sitting american
presidents during her lifetime again
showing the deep involvement she
personally had in maintaining those
close ties between the u.s and the
united kingdom joining us now is the u.s
ambassador to the united kingdom jane
hartley madame ambassador good morning
to you
there is no closer ally to the united
states than the united kingdom and the
queen had a role in maintaining those
ties what was it how would you describe
the work she did over the years keeping
these two countries so close together
well first of all i think she loved
america and we we loved her
uh when i first arrived um it was right
before platinum jubilee um and i was
amazed at the number of people on the
street
um that just adored her and and there
was so much respect but there were many
many americans there and uh during that
time one woman from california was
quoted in the new york times as saying
she's our queen
too
um and that is i think the relationship
we had with her
um i i can tell you in terms of the
special relationship
uh i've been here a few months now
it is like none other and whether that
be
intelligence military
the uk is truly our number one ally
we've heard uh madame ambassador that
she was kind that she was generous also
funny you had the opportunity to meet
her a time or two even in those brief
moments i wonder what impression did you
get of her as a person
well exactly that
i met her when i presented credentials
to her which is a tradition that a u.s
ambassador when they first get to london
does that it's quite it's quite a formal
process
uh and the day i presented it happened
to be the hottest day in london history
so usually they have a stranger
i apologize we're up against the
computer taking us off the air which i
would not want to happen i appreciate
your reflections this morning
ahead to our viewers we have the
peerless royal watcher tina brown stay
with us